Film Courage: Do you think it’s a mistake
for a filmmaker to think about distribution
after they’ve made the movie?
Mark Heidelberger, producer: Yes.
I absolutely, 100 percent think it is a mistake
to only start thinking about marketing and
distribution after the film is done.
And again, I’m going to say more things
that are going to piss people off…is I really
think the film schools have it all wrong.
And I mentioned that guy that I spoke with
recently who I just feel like I wouldn’t
get along with and he’s one of these guys
who is “I’m just doing it for the passion.”
And I explained to him there is a reason we
call it show business and no show-show (and
I stole that from Peter Guber by the way)
who was one of my professors at UCLA.
He used to say that “It’s not show-show.
It’s show business.”
If you just want to go out and make a piece
of art for yourself and you have the money
to blow, you know go ahead.
But that doesn’t mean you are going to be
part of the entertainment industry.
That doesn’t mean you are going to be part
of the film…business.
It is a business, it is a commodity as well
as art.
That’s where people get hung up.
It’s art right, but it’s art but it’s
also a commodity and people sacrifice one
for the other.
And I read an article a couple months ago
and it just…oh my God…my head…it was
like a cartoon my head was just like [makes
a loud noise as if steam is going out].
I was so annoyed with this article.
It just started with “Okay, now you’ve
finished your film.
Now it’s time to start thinking about distribution.”
I’m like “No!
No!
It’s not!
It’s time to start thinking about distribution
ages ago.
From the script stage you should have been
thinking about distribution.”
And I’ve told filmmakers that I’ve worked
with, the smart way to do it is (and they
always have a script that they really want
to do) and I say have you considered your
audience?
Have you considered whether there’s an audience
for it?
Have you considered how you are going to get
that audience?
Have you considered how big that audience
is and whether it justifies the budget you
want to spend and etc., etc.
Have you looked t the market and seen what
other films are just like it in the market,
how over-saturated it is.
I can’t tell you how many times I’ve heard
people say “I’m going to do horror because
it’s so cheap.”
So you can make a bunch of money off of it
but you are only considering one thing, you
are only considering budget.
You are not considering drawbacks of horror
like when you go to AFM [American Film Market]
there are 18 other films with posters that
look exactly like yours, all competing for
that same shelf space or that distributor
who only has a budget to acquire so many films.
You are not considering the fact that a lot
of name talent doesn’t like to do horror,
which I was up against on my latest film THE
BASEMENT.
Even casting directors know that, a lot of
casting directors don’t want to touch horror
because they know a lot of name actors just
avoid horror movies.
Which is why so many times you see horror
movies with nobody in it you really recognize.
Unless it’s like really smart, different
kind of horror, maybe you see some people
take a chance on it.
But they are not necessarily looking at it
like a business.
I tell people there is no other industry in
which you would spend millions of millions
of millions on R&D and developing widgets
and mass-producing widgets “I’m going
to set up a big manufacturing space (a big
warehouse), I’m going to make widgets and
I’ve got this whole staff of people boxing
up widgets.
And then when I’m done I’m going to have
this whole warehouse of widgets.”
And then when I’m done I’m like “Okay,
now let me figure out how I can sell these.”
No, you identify a need in the market.
Like hey this…people are renting or buying
these kind of movies and there is definitely
an opportunity here.
And I have a great story I think I can tell
within that.
And consulting with distributors and sales
agents that know the market place.
And if you’re afraid to get the distributors
and sales agents involved early and find out
what the market looks like and what buyers
are looking for and what budget ranges those
pictures are in and which ones are making
money, if you don’t to do that and then
you make a picture and make no money you know
you really don’t have anyone to blame but
yourself.
It’s absolutely the end use and the marketing,
distribution and publicity, festivals all
that, you should be looking at that from the
beginning, from inception of the story.
And so a lot of times it falls on deaf ears.
I always advise filmmakers “You should get
sales agents and distributors involved from
the get-go.”
I’m not saying it’s going to make it fool-proof
that you are going to make a return-on-your-investment
because of that, but it’s going to (I think)
get you a lot closer.
Are they always right?
No.
I mean they can be wrong as well.
But they know a lot more than we do.
Just like you trust a DP to shoot the picture
because he knows more about lighting and camera
than you do.
Or an editor because he knows a lot more about
cutting than you do.
Distributors and sales agents know more about
selling in the market than you do.
And so if you want some chance at getting
some sort of better return, involve people
that know more about what they do than you
do.
And I say this all the time when I hire people.
I say “Look, I hired you because you know
more about what you do than I know about what
you do.
So I’m going to tell you the result I want.
I’m going to tell you when I want it by
and I’m going to tell you what resources
I’m going to give you to give me that result.
And I you say ‘I can do it.’
I’m going to say “Great, go do it then.”
And I’m here to support you, you tell me
hey I need you to do this or that as long
as it is within those parameters, done.
If there’s a problem, we’ll fix it and
we’ll make sure it doesn’t happen again.
So trust but verify but I don’t stand over
their shoulders making sure…I hired you
because this is what you do and you’re better
at it than I am.
So go do it.
And the crew loves that.
The sales agents and distributors, treat them
like part of your team because by the time
people have made their movie and come to the
distributor, the distributors are like “Well
there is not much we can do with it now.
We can try to craft a marketing campaign.
But if you had this person in it and if you
had only spent this much and if you had done
these things with the story, we’d be in
a lot better of a position.
Now all we have, we didn’t have any say
in the story or script, we didn’t have any
say in the casting, we didn’t have any say
in the budget, now all we have is the marketing
campaign.
But we’re stuck with the movie we have,
there’s not much we can do with it now.
So I am absolutely a fan of people getting
distributors and sales agents or talking to
them, producer’s reps.
Whoever you can that knows the marketplace,
get them involved as early as possible.